ein weltraum aufzug der die erde mit dem
all verbindet für immer science fiction
oder bald schon realität es gibt leute
die diese konzepte für weltraum lifts
technologischen heutzutage für umsetzbar
halten
ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
gewünscht wir übrigens dahin kommt zu
whatsapp dass herr vater am ende des
videos und bekommt jetzt alle wirklich
spannenden facts zum thema weltraum auf
züge wie weit ist die technik und wo
hakt es also herzlich willkommen bei
klicks um science-fiction
seit dem neunzehnten jahrhundert denken
die menschen über die idee des weltraum
lifts nach und erfüllt ganze science
fiction drehbücher und literatur und das
konzept hat ja wirklich was die erde und
der weltraum sind verbunden durch einen
aufzug der uns menschen aber auch fracht
mal eben von a nach b und zwar von der
erde nach oben bringt ganz und raketen
sie wären also eine preiswerte
alternative zur raumfahrt denn jedes
kilogramm das mit einer rakete die
erdanziehung überwinden muss ist teuer
der vorteil eines lifts er würde sich
eher langsam bewegen dafür aber eine
größere menge transportieren können und
dass eben zu einem viel geringeren preis
konkret kann man sich das seil des lifts
ein wenig vorstellen wie die
kletterseile in der sporthalle der
aufzug ist quasi ein geostationärer
satelliten der bis zur erde herunter
reicht diese satelliten sind in ihrer
umlaufgeschwindigkeit in einer höhe von
36.000 kilometern mit der
drehgeschwindigkeit der erde
synchronisiert sie sind also an einem
fixen punkt am himmel
in knapp 24 stunden drehen sie sich also
einmal mit um die erde
der experte für dieses thema ist der
physiker bradley boards seit 1998 hat er
verschiedene arbeiten und bücher zur
weltraum auf cd veröffentlicht darin
suchte nach ideen um probleme wie etwa
die stromversorgung zu lösen
2001 und 2002 veröffentlichte er studien
von der nasa unterstützt unter anderem
stellt der errechnung an nach denen ein
solcher weltraum aufzug die kosten von
shuttle mission um ein vielfaches
reduzieren würden zitat wenn man es
wirklich wollte könnte man schon in
naher zukunft mit dem bau eines weltraum
lifts beginnen
das sagt etwas er stellt sich den ersten
aufzug ins all folgendermaßen vor von
einem satelliten lässt man ein etwa
100.000 kilometer langes seil herunter
es muss länger sein
dazu kommen wir gleich auf eine
plattform auf der erde da wird es enden
ähnlich wie eine ölplattform die
schwimmt dadurch würde man das seil
manövrieren können um weltraummüll etwa
auszuweichen oder die bewegungen des
seils auszutarieren das salz würde sich
ähnlich verhalten wie bei einem
hammerwurf es spannt sich aufgrund der
drehbewegung des hammerwerfer also im
übertragenen
der erde weil die hammer kugel also der
satellit nach außen gezogen wird die
vision weltraum aufzüge bei denen man in
einer höhe von 60 bis 70 tausend
kilometern aussteigen kann und zwar auf
den mond oder aber man fährt weiter
richtung mars oder jupiter das tolle es
gäbe kaum einschränkungen hinsichtlich
der größe und des gewichts der fracht
draußen im weltraum auch die
energiekosten während im vergleich zu
raketen kaum erwähnenswert bei allen
technischen überlegungen ist tatsächlich
das sei die letzte große schwierigkeit
ist muss stark genug sein wind aushalten
und nicht unter dem eigenen gewicht
reißen das war bisher immer das größte
problem etwas lösung kohlenstoff
nanoröhrchen seiner ansicht nach wäre es
längst möglich sie in passender länge
und menge herzustellen
denn sie sind zum einen extrem leicht
und zum anderen extrem reißfest ein
farben mit einem durchmesser achtung von
nur 0,5 millimeter kann zwei tonnen
tragen ein kilometer dieses sei aber
wiegt dabei nur 400 gramm wow doch
andere experten bezweifeln dass denn nur
weil man ein potenzielles
ausgangsmaterial gefunden habe sei das
laufen längst nicht das endprodukt saal
das benötigt wird dennoch gibt es schon
einige ernsthafte interessenten die das
konzept in die praxis umsetzen wollen
beispielsweise das amerikanische
unternehmen lift port die vorarbeiten
sollen über crowdfunding finanziert
werden und der gründer ist sich sicher
es ist sehr gut möglich einen aufzug zum
mond zu bauen das komplette projekt
würde schätzungen zufolge wohl rund 15
milliarden dollar kosten aber für
investoren ist das risiko groß wann sind
alle studien abgeschlossen werden die
entsprechenden genehmigungen erteilt
dabei ist etwas zur folge der space
elevator tatsächlich die einzig
wirkliche alternative zu raketen nicht
nur weltraumteleskope könnten ins all
gebracht werden möglich wäre plötzlich
auch der bergbau auf planeten wie dem
mars oder jupiter dort gibt es große
vorkommen an seltenen erden aber
natürlich könnte der aufzug auch uns
menschen hoch bringen vielleicht wäre er
sogar der schlüssel um den mars viel
einfacher zu besiedeln wenn er als
erstes neues zum thema weltraum aufzug
und zu allen anderen themen erfahren
wollt dann meldet euch hierbei
dann erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich vor
allen anderen vom neuesten video eben
vor ab und garantiert ihr können dort
direkt in der redaktion von pixum
mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen
oder andere vorschläge machen der
direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das
aber mit der genau wer glocke vergessen
und hier geht es weiter mit dafür drauf
kriegen 3d druck revolutioniert die
raumfahrt ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran